depuis la crise du sras en 2003 les
hôpitaux ont agi pour prévenir les
risques de contagion
c'est une pièce a été conçue dans neuf
salles d'attentes pour en fait pour les
gens qui se présentent avec fièvre et
toux
ensuite un protocole est appliqué pour
ceux qui présentent ces symptômes et qui
arrivent de l'étranger
suite à ça l'infirmer avoir regardé la
liste qui lui fournit des pays où il ya
une vigilance accrue en l'occurrence ici
la chine pour le nouveau corner virus et
on a amélioré le niveau de sécurité des
salles qui accueillerait les patients
infectés qui si on entre dans ce qu'on
appelle la chambre où le sas
d'abord l'antichambre pour éviter que le
personnel transportent des infections
dans la salle de traitement
la dernière pièce on arrive en
franchissant la deuxième pas c'est à
proprement parler la cham à pression
négative de réalisation une chambre
parfaitement étanche pour encore une
fois traitée la personne infectée en
prévenant une contagion potentiel les
portes sont même dotés d'un passe plat
pour éviter la contagion lors du
transport des repas
c'est pas mal ce fait mieux qu'on a ici
ça a été adapté aussi au fil des années
à force de simulation des pratiques de
cocon husson l'adapter vraiment nos
besoins qu'on est capable de fournir des
soins de grande qualité qui regarde bien
une protection optimale de travailleurs
visiteurs patients les équipes sont aux
aguets mais ici personne ne semble pas
nick et on sait que les masques la de
protection pour elle toutes les
symptômes respiratoires bon les box vide
que rapidement là mais rien de
particulier québec est à établir la
liste des hôpitaux qui comme sacré coeur
ont l'équipement nécessaire pour
accueillir un éventuel cas de
coronavirus ici david gêne-t-il et radio
canada
bon rien